sometimes yes the wife is required to
make an effort she's not always going to
feel like it can I ask you a question so
if you didn't feel like it you still do
it if he wanted to yes like I wrote
Because he needs me I just feel like the
man it's not always I'm horny it's their
way of connecting to you they want to be
close to you and they don't want to sit
down and have a gossip about what they
did they don't want to listen to your
like stories that you say is going to be
two minutes but actually it's an hour
and a half they want to connect that way
just sometimes you have to Avail
yourself if you don't feel like it read
the book bend over and just like you
know